bienvenue à toutes et tous ceux qui
découvrent la télé tout court d'ailleurs
parce que c'est vrai qu'avant d'être un
objet pour streamer et jouer à des jeux
vidéo en fait il y avait des programmes
qui étaient dedans et on disait on
regarde la télé voilà une petite
anecdote
pour les plus jeunes la Coupe du Monde a
donc débuté hier avec ce match
d'ouverture Équateur Qatar après la
cérémonie d'ouverture j'ai regardé vous
avez regardé j'ai regardé j'ai été
agréablement déçu c'est toujours chiant
c'est une cérémonie d'ouverture alors
petit bémol il y avait pas le porteur de
drapeau français parce qu'il s'est
blessé à l'entraînement
c'est lors de notre point cathare 2022
qui est sponsorisé par les partenaires
retrouvez la Coupe du Monde 2022 au
Qatar avec de l'eau plate des patchs
photos pour le mal de dos Christine
Boutin et Mondial Assistance hier un
jeune homme très handicapé s'est avancé
au centre du stade en compagnie de
l'acteur noir américain Morgan Freeman
il s'appelle ce jeune homme ganim al
mufta il est qatari il 20 ans il souffre
d'une maladie très rare qui se
caractérise par une absence de vertèbres
et qui fait que très concrètement il a
une tête et le haut du corps d'une
taille absolument normal mais le reste
du corps absolument minuscule si bien
que debout il dépasse à peine les genoux
de Morgan Freeman pas beaucoup de stars
pas beaucoup de stars il y avait s'il y
avait Marcel de sel de saillie un groupe
de puceau coréens qui sont et si quand
même très fort si s'il y avait quand
même Nelson Mandela ça il est mort
Nelson Mandela alors c'était Morgan
Freeman
tous les deux l'alcool qui devait être
autorisé près des stades et finalement
interdit ça va faire bizarre aux
supporters surtout aux Anglais quand ils
vont découvrir que sur un terrain il y a
pas 66 joueurs mais juste 22
des supporters
[Musique]
tu sais ce qu'on a l'impression oui je
vais te le dire après que tu es une
enterrement de vie de garçon et qu'on
t'a déguisé
pourquoi les lunettes bières comme ça là
j'aime bien les bières ok je suis belle
aussi attends
match
la bière il y en a bien eu au Qatar
notamment dans la fin de zone on
attendait il faut le dire avec un peu de
curiosité ce premier match ce premier
test grandeur nature au stade al byte au
nord de Doha et ce qui a beaucoup fait
parler en effet au-delà de la cérémonie
et du match d'ouverture et bien c'est la
climatisation il y en avait une sous
chaque siège on était tous morts de
froid on est Équateur on a des régions
où il fait froid mais ici c'était pire
pire que chez nous chez vous en Europe
on avait les pieds gelés on se couvrait
avec notre drapeau on avait envie qu'ils
éteignent cette climatisation
climatisation activée oui et toi du
stade ouvert il ne faisait pourtant que
25 degrés dehors pendant ce match
Qatar Équateur c'est bientôt Noël du
coup je me suis dit
on fait un mélange entre 5
du coup voilà je trouvais ça sympa je me
suis dit c'est dans le thème voilà il se
pointe avec deux boules au niveau des
tétons et des parties génitales donc je
me dis les mecs c'est pas trop quoi ou
alors moi je suis à l'ouest j'adore tes
plumes mais les boules elles sont bien
placées
c'est bien ferme tes boules c'est je
vois que ils brillent le geste est
univoque ce supporter équatoriant en est
convaincu l'arbitre de Qatar Équateur le
match d'ouverture de la Coupe du Monde a
été acheté et il le dit haut et fort
juste devant des Cathares il faut dire
que le hors-jeu sifflait dès la deuxième
minute après un but des équatoriens
était difficile à voir à fortiori depuis
les gradins sur les réseaux sociaux
aussi beaucoup ont contesté la décision
évoquant un arbitrage corrompu jusqu'à
réinventer la ligne de hors-jeu en forme
du drapeau du Qatar c'est la Coupe du
monde la plus chère de tous les temps et
de très loin elle a coûté cette Coupe du
Monde on va voir plus de 200 milliards
pour faire une comparaison la Coupe du
monde en Russie il y a en 2018 avec
coûté 11 milliards d'euros
15 pour avoir quelque chose d'aussi cher
et 220 milliards c'est quoi c'est le
programme Apollo pour aller sur la Lune
ça a coûté ça a coûté mais moins cher la
NASA estime que d'ici 10 ans grâce à la
mission Artémis on sait il y a quelques
jours des êtres humains vivront sur la
lune et Artémis n'est pas la première à
viser la lune puisqu'il y avait déjà
Apollo en 72 mais surtout Amel Bent en
2004 la définition de l'univers c'était
posée son engin comme en 69 très belle
définition merci Jacky quant à ceux qui
s'inquiétait du sort du père de famille
une deuxième vidéo montre les deux
hommes main dans la main
passion ou pression le doute plane déjà
sur la compétition
les premiers habitants seront
principalement des scientifiques qui
tenteront de comprendre comment un
paysage a pu autant sans avoir été géré
par Anne Hidalgo
que se passe-t-il oui depuis 12 jours
maintenant le propriétaire de ces
moutons se pose la question que se
passe-t-il oui Jean-Baptiste jour et
nuit regardez ce troupeau ne cesse de
tourner en rond ça se passe dans un
élevage en Chine plusieurs dizaines de
bêtes ont adopté ce comportement tout à
fait mystérieux alors aucune explication
claire n'a encore été donnée mais des
vétérinaires évoquent la possible piste
de la listériose
[Rires]
[Musique]
là j'ai vraiment peur